الان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه فردت بصد قواتها
52 هجوما للقوات الروسيه على محاور باخمت
وليمن وافديافكا ومارينكا بمقاطعه دونتسك
الشرقيه اوكرانيا واكدت الهيئه ان القوات
الروسيه حاول التنفيذ هجوم على بلدتي
غريغوريفيكا وخروموفو شمال غربي بخموت الى
ان القوات الاوكرانيه افشلته بينما تواصل
القوات الروسيه محاوله السيطره الكامله
على المدينه رغم المعارك الشرسه وتكبدها
خسائر كبيره ومن جانب اخر اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اليوم مقتل 10 جنود
اوكرانيين خلال الساعات 24 الماضيه على
محور خرسن وتدمير مدفعين ذاتيي الحركه
قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القصف
الروسيه ما زال مستمرا على مقاطاعتي خرسون
وزابولوجيا جنوبيه البلاد وبحسب العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في خرسون شنت القوات الروسيه
خلال الساعات الماضيه اكثر من 50 هجوما
على مناطق مدينه مناطق مدنيه موقع اضرار
الماديه وفي المقابل اكد الجيش الاوكرانيه
ان قوته قصفت مواقع للقوات الروسيه في
ريفزاف الجنوبيه
معنى من دنيتك مراسلنا بابا ولد حرمه ومن
كييف مراسلنا تامر الصمادي وابدا معك بابا
ولد حرمه واخر التطورات واين تتركز
العمليات العسكريه هناك
وجنوبا في منطقه في منطقه
لا يتبادل الطرفان المدفعيه
على هذا على هذا المحور بل كذلك يتبادلون
الاسرع بالامس اعلنت وزاره الدفاع عن
روسيا انها استعاده
وسته جنود كانوا في قبضه الاوكرانيين بعد
مفاوضات مع الجانبيه الاوكراني بدورها
اوكرانيا اعلنت كذلك انها استلمت 100
جنديا اوكرانيا كانوا في قبضه الروس طبعا
يتواصل تتواصل هذه الاشتباكات على طول
الجبهات تتحدث
الجهات روسيا مصادر عسكريه روسيا ومواقع
عسكريه روسيا بالاحرى عن هذا عن هذه
المواجهات الدائره في منطقه باخموت القائم
باعمال الحكومه المحليه في دنيا المواليه
لروسيا
بوشيل تحدث عن سيطره قوات على اكثر من
في المئه من مساحه هذه المدينه التي تعرف
معارك شرسه ومواجهات محتدمه ومتواصله منذ
عده ايام بل منذ عده اسابيع
بينر والقوات الروسيه والقوه الاوكرانيه
تقول مواقع عسكريه روسيا ان السيطره
الاوكرانيين تنحسر في الجزء الغربي من
المدينه هو ان قوه
تحقق بعض التقدم من الجهه الجنوبيه ومن
الشرق ومن الشمالي الشرقي ومن الجهه
الشماليه وان هناك معاركه محتدمه تدور
بالتحديد في منطقه او في محيط محطه السكه
الحديديه الرئيسيه في المنطقه ونقواته
مثلا استولت على بعضها المنشات من بينها
الملعب المركزي في المدينه بالاضافه الى
بعض المنشات مثل المدارس في هذه المدينه
وفق المصادر الع
وفق المواقع العسكريه الروسيه ومسؤولين
عسكريين لروسيا في دنيا ابقى معنا ايضا
بابا والحرمه من دنيت من
الجزيره التامر صمادي يعني انباء المعارك
طبعا
والتصريحات الخاصه بها موجوده لكن ماذا عن
التسريبات ماذا عن الانباء القادمه من
واشنطن وقد وجد الاوكرانيون انفسهم وقد
عرضت خططهم للربيع لمعركه الربيع على رؤوس
الاشهاد
العابدين في الحقيقه الموقف من التسريبات
الموقف الاوكراني الرسمي يعني يقابل بصمت
هنا استطيع ان اقول بانه موقف صامت حتى
هذه اللحظه باستثناء بعض التصريحات التي
صدرت عن عدد من المسؤولين السياسيين خلال
الايام الماضيه والتي اشاروا فيها الى ان
هذه
لعب روسيه لا يريدون الانخراط بها وانما
يتم تسريب غير دقيق وفقا لقوات الاوكرانيه
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه لكن بالتاكيد
التصريحات السياسيه هنا متواصله فيما
يتعلق بمزيد من الدعم العسكري للجبهات وهو
ما اشار اليه الرئيس الاوكراني الليله
الماضيه في خطابه اليومي حيث قال بان
الدعم يتواصل من المانيا وانه يطالب دول
العالم والدول الشريكه بضروره ارسال مزيد
من الدعم الى الجبهات في شرق البلا
وجنوبها وتحدث بشكل يعني خاص عن باخموت
بالاضافه الى زبروجيا وخيرسون جنوبي
البلاد وقال بان مزيد من المساعدات
العسكريه الى الجبهات يعني حمايه الدول
الشريكه وليس حمايه اوكرانيا فقط وقال
ايضا بان هذا الدعم العسكري سيحمي كل شخص
في اوروبا وذهب الى ابعد من ذلك مؤكدا بان
العمليات تتواصل وبان الامور تسير الى
صالح الكفه الاوكرانيه في طول البلاد
وعرضها هذه التصريحات ايضا ترافقت مع
تصريح لوزير الدفاع الاوكراني الذي قال
بان الوقت يمضي لصالح الجيش الاوكراني
فيما يتعلق بالهجوم المضاد وقال بان هذا
الهجوم المضاد سيبدا سيتواصل سيتكاثف
سيتكاثف عفوا مع مرور الوقت لكن مجلس
الامن القومي الاوكراني قال بان الهجوم
المضاد يمضي كل يوم ويتصاعد ايضا في كل
يوم ولكنه اكد بانه لا تواريخ محدده في
اشاره الى الهجوم المتكرره الذي تتحدث عنه
القوات الاوكرانيه في الربيع
والصيف وقال بانه يجب التكتم على
المعلومات العسكريه لانجاح هذه المهمات في
الجنوب في الشرق وكانت في الحقيقه هنالك
تصريحات لوزير الدفاع اخرى خلال احاطه
صحفيه مع وزير الدفاع الدنماركي في اوديسا
قال فيها بان القوات الاوكرانيه تحضر
لمفاجات للقوات الروسيه المتواجده في
البحر الاسود وقال بان المساله مساله وقت
وبان العمل يجري على قدم وساق لاستهداف
سفن للقوات الروسيه في البحر الاسود هذا
التصريح جاء بعد تاكيدات لقياده عمليات
الجنوب بان القوات الروسيه تعزز من
تواجدها في البحر الاسود ونهايه ال ال
التطورات العسكريه تتواصل في باق موت
القوات الاوكرانيه تقول انها صدت اكثر من
50 هجوما خلال الساعات الماضيه على محور
او محاور بخموت والايمان وابدي يفكه
ومارينكا وبالتاكيد ننقسم ايضا يتواصل
الروسي بطبيعه الحال على مقاطعه
جنوبا كيف
بابا ولد حرمه شكرا جزيلا لكما